big boys don't cry
suck it up shut up and rub some dirt on
it
stop crying before i give you something
to cry about
these are just a few of the phrases that
contribute to a disease in our society
and more specifically in our men
it's a disease that has come to be known
as toxic masculinity
it's one i suffered a chronic case of so
much so
that i spent 24 years of a life sentence
in prison for kidnapping
robbery and attempted murder
yet i'm here to tell you today that
there's a solution for this epidemic
i know for a fact the solution works
because i was a part of human trials
the solution is a mixture of elements
it begins with the willingness to look
at your belief system and how out of
alignment it is
and how your actions negatively impact
not just yourself but the people around
you
the next ingredient is a willingness to
be vulnerable with people
who will not just support you but hold
you accountable
but before i tell you about this i need
to let you know that in order to share
this
i have to bear my soul in full
and as i stand here with so many eyes
fixed on me
i feel raw and naked
when this feeling is present i'm
confident that the next phase of healing
is on the horizon
and that allows me to share my story in
full
for all appearances sake i was born into
the ideal
family dynamic mother father sister
brother bertha eldridge jr
teddy ma and eldridge iii that's me
my father was a vietnam veteran who
earned a purple heart and made it home
to find love
marry and begin his own brew
so how did i wind up serving life in the
california prison system
keeping secrets believing the mantra
that big boys don't cry
not knowing how to display any emotion
confidently other than anger
participating in athletics and learning
that the greater the performance on the
field the less the need to worry about
the rules off it
it's hard to pin down any one specific
ingredient of the many symptoms
that held me growing up as a young black
male
in sacramento california in the 1980s
there were two groups i identified as
having
respect athletes and gangsters
i excelled in sports that is until a
friend and i chose to take his mom's car
for a joyride and wreck it
with my parents having to split the cost
of a total vehicle
i was relegated to a summer of household
chores
and no sports no sports
meant no respect no respect equaled no
power
power was vital to feed my illness
it was at that point the decision to
transition
from athlete to gangster
was made and done so easily
early life experiences had set the stage
for me to be well suited
to objectify others
act in a socially detached manner and
above all else
seek to be viewed as in a position of
power
a sense of power
equaled strength in my environment but
more importantly it did so in my mind
my mind dictated my choices
my subsequent choices put me on the fast
track to prison life
and even once in prison i continued my
history of running over the rights of
others
even knowing that that was the place
that i would die
once again i wound up in solitary
confinement
for stabbing another prisoner nearly 30
times
i'd gotten to a place where i didn't
care how i lived or if i died
but then things changed one of the best
things that happened in my life to that
point was being sent to new folsom
prison
once there i was approached to join a
group called inside circle
initially i was hesitant to join a group
referred to around the yard as
hug a thug
initially that was
yeah that was a little much but
eventually i overcame my hesitancy
as it turned out the circle was the
vision
of a man named patrick nolan who was
also serving life
and who had grown sick and tired of
being sick
and tired of watching us kill one
another
over skin color rag color
being from northern or southern
california
or just plain breathing in the wrong
direction on a windy day
circle time is men sitting with men and
cutting through the [ __ ]
challenging structural ways of thinking
i think the way that i think
and i act the way that i act because i
haven't questioned that
like who said i should see a woman
walking down the street
turn around and check out her backside
where did that come from
if i don't question that i'll just go
along with the crowd
the locker room talk in circle we sit
and we question these things
why do i think the way that i think why
do i act the way that i act
because when i get down to it i'm not
thinking
i'm not being an individual i'm not
taking responsibility for who i
am and what it is i put into this world
it was in a circle session that my life
took a turn
i remember being asked who i was and i
didn't have an answer
at least not one that felt honest in a
room full of men who were seeking truth
it would have been easy to say i'm a
blood
or my name is vegas or any number of
facades i had manufactured to hide
behind
it was in that moment and in that venue
that the jig was
up i realized that as sharp as i
believed i was
i didn't even know who i was or why i
acted the way that i acted
i couldn't stand in a room full of men
who were seeking to serve and support
and present an authentic me
it was in that moment that i graduated
to a place within that was ready for
transformation
for decades i kept being the victim of
molestation at the hands of a babysitter
a secret
i submitted to this under the threat of
my younger sister being harmed
i was seven she was three
i believed it was my responsibility to
keep her safe
it was in that instant that the seeds
were sown
for a long career of hurting others be
it physical
mental or emotional
i developed in that instant
at seven years old the belief that going
forward in life if a situation
presented itself where someone was going
to get hurt
i would be the one doing the hurting i
also formulated the belief that
loving put me in harm's way
i also learned that caring about another
person
made me weak so not caring
that must equal strength
the greatest way to mask a shaky sense
of self is to hide behind a false air of
respect
sitting in circle resembles sitting in a
fire
it is a crucial that can and does break
it broke my old sense of self
diseased value system
and way of looking at others
my old stale modes of thinking were
invited into the open
to see if this is who i wanted to be in
life
i was accompanied by skilled
facilitators on a journey
into the depths of myself to find those
wounded parts
that not only festered but seeped out to
create unsafe space for others
at times it resembled an exorcism and in
essence it was
there was an extraction of old disease
ways of thinking
being and reacting and an infusion of
purpose
sitting in those circles saved my life
i stand here today as a testament to the
fact
of the power of the word
i was paroled in june 2014
following my third hearing before a
panel of former law enforcement
officials who were tasked with
determining
my current threat level to society
i stand here today for the first time
since i was 14 years old not under any
form of state supervision
i'm married to a tremendous woman named
holly and together we're raising two
sons
who i encourage to experience
emotions in a safe way i let them hold
me when i cry
they get to witness me not have all the
answers
my desire is for them to understand that
being a man
is not some machismo caricature
and that characteristics usually defined
as weaknesses
are parts of the whole healthy man so
today i continue the work not just on
myself
but in support of young males in my
community
the challenge is to eradicate the cycle
of emotional illiteracy and groupthink
that allows our males
to continue to victimize others as well
as themselves
as a result of this they develop new
ways
of how they want to show up in the world
and how they expect this world to show
up on their behalf
thank you